all right so let's go to the rest of
that game because there's another player
we need to talk about well and this one
this is another example of officiating
issues with the National Football League
if you're watching on the New Orleans
Saints clearly a fumble clearly out what
cam Jordan clearly gone the problem is
the ruling on the field was an
incomplete pass so be a replay review
you can overturn that right right you
can give the Saints possession because
there was a clear recovery but it is so
clearly out but you can't advance it and
I remember remember the Ed Hochuli
Chargers Broncos game from 10 plus years
ago when the rule was you couldn't even
recover it right play it was dead at
that there right right at least you can
recover it but that wasn't much solace
for the Saints because it went from 10
to 3
- they didn't score - the rams got a
field goal so it ended up being a
10-point swing but that was a horrendous
call and various former officials who
are now in the media said look they've
they're always told don't blow that
whistle yeah I mean let it right let it
play out and this one wasn't even close
I mean the miles Jack thing from the AFC
Championship game a couple of years ago
when he that was close why some legs
touching and flying around and it's one
of those when you watch it in slow
motion like oh my god the ball was out
he somehow scooped it up and he was gone
even touched it right this one wasn't
close there's no excuse for this no
excuse this is like referee 101 really
basically this type of play not sure if
the ball came out and not sure if it's a
forward pass let it roll don't blow the
whistle don't call it and complete this
is you you err on the side of clunky and
a turnover
why because turnovers are always
automatically reviewed so that was a
huge mistake I don't know what's going
on with the Saints in the referees I
mean this is three games in a row now
and I did I don't know if someone down
in New Orleans put the voodoo hex on
them or they got our review they got a
re reverse the voodoo hex or something
yeah if it's someone from New Orleans
who likes the Saints whatever they did
isn't working yes right I don't know
yeah so let me I don't know if they put
voodoo on the Saints so they gotta take
I don't know but I just I feel for the
Saints that they keep getting bitten by
this bad referee bug here and that was a
huge turning point the game because you
mentioned it yeah
now that the Saints got the ball back
they went forward on a fourth and one
didn't get it at midfield and then
subsequently the Rams got the ball and
ended up kicking the field the NFL may
put a little voodoo on Sean Payton's
wall at first comments after the game
let's hear from Coach Payton in response
to what transpired on Sunday we get poor
officiating or we get an awful call like
that we can't control that so our focus
this week is going to be on cleaning up
the penalties and making sure we got the
right guys on the field to look he
didn't come out and say directly it was
a horrible call he just said hey when
horrible calls happen like that one then
you just have he's didn't get away with
that anyway the way you use that it was
very nice just I just wonder whether he
will or he won't and I wonder how much
the NFL wants to continue shining a
spotlight on the horrible call by
finding hide that so that the call
careful there right there's a lower
standard for players here's cam Jordan
with his thoughts on what happened in
the game on Sunday you say a touchdown
got taken away I mean I didn't even hear
the whistle I grabbed the ball 15 20
yards down and allegedly I was so blown
clearly I mean Louis was blown where
normally you let the play happen and he
footlocker
I mean referee usually tells you you let
the play happen and then you go back and
review the play you're fined for call
original joke footlocker right and you
know you can either cry or you can laugh
and if you're a Saints fan you just have
to wonder what in the hell is going on
and you know what here's the thing yeah
it's by far not your biggest problem
your biggest problem is you may not have
Drew Brees for an extended period of
time no doubt so who cares about what
because here's the thing even if it's 10
3 right at that point yeah they really
gonna win that you know maybe not you're
right you're right they probably
wouldn't needed another type of
defensive play to don't win the football
game or something but it certainly
changed the the total outlook of the
game
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports